- Do you believe in
like supernatural stuff?
Have you ever seen ghosts or stuff?
I haven't and I want to.
- Oh, come over to my house.
Yes, I have.
- I dunno if they show themselves to me.
- Thank God they haven't
actually shown themselves,
'cause I don't know if I
wouldn't be here right now.
- I would want to see it.
- You think that.
You think that.
- No, I 100% think it would be cool.
- Okay, well I have, yeah,
I've had some things happen.
I've lost both my parents and
Like a lot of things happen, especially
after my mom passed away,
or very strange things
happen, like lights going on
where they weren't even plugged
in, really weird things.
- Yeah.
- So, I have no doubt I believe in that.
And then my house that I live
in now was built in like 1882
and moved by like trolley in 1912.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I hear footsteps a lot.
Every one in my family
has heard the footsteps.
- Yeah.
- And Smokey Robinson
actually used to own my home
and I was at an Oscar
party this past Oscars
and he said, "Oh, have you
heard the footsteps yet?"
I did not need to hear that.
(audience laughing)
I was like, I wanted to believe
that I was imagining it.
But the funny thing is
it feels safe though.
It's like a good spirit.
- Yeah, I don't feel unsafe around it.
Yeah.
- But we've seen the movies,
we don't know what's gonna happen.
- Those are movies though.
I really wanna see one, Kyle, okay.